foreign
[Music]
the only thing I have from the dad I
never knew is
we must be brothers that's just brothers
Trevor twins wow we're twins we're
[__] identical twins if mom and dad
got married again then we'd have a real
family what if we trick them into
getting back together
what are you doing here the twins
[Music]
the services
should I open another bottle I know it's
our second but we're not Baptist
way y'all
I'm gay queer is a three dollar bill in
just as thin
my [__] hand job
[Applause]
[Music]
wow a lady boss I guess it really is the
year that it is
I'm so sorry did you say sewer boys
disgusting they're not disgusting
they're gay coaches
oh
[Music]